New York City police called two
unprovoked attacks on officers by the
same alleged gunman assassination
attempts surveillance video shows the
suspect his name is Robert Williams
apparently walking into a police station
and officers running for cover after
gunshots rang out this all unfolded less
than 12 hours after an officer was
wounded inside a police van or lead
national correspondent that's David
Wagner was at the 41st precinct the
Bronx where Williams was captured
David this video very chilling what do
you know about him well Gail if
detectives know why he did this they
haven't told us just yet what we do know
is he has a lengthy criminal history he
actually served time in prison for
attempted murder and was released
recently he walked through the front
door of that NYPD precinct and started
shooting this is not a crime gone bad
this is a premeditated assassination
attempt that is New York City's Police
Commissioner he called the suspect a
coward
the city's mayor condemned the violence
on New York's finest an attack on a
police officer is an attack on all of us
surveillance video appears to show 45
year-old Robert Williams walk into the
precinct and start shooting uniformed
officers and civilians were scrambling
for cover Williams shot a police
lieutenant in the arm before running out
of bullets and that gave the officers
just enough time to swarm him and arrest
him and if it wasn't for the men and
women at a 41st precinct it could have
been even worse than this police say
Williams began his rampage Saturday
night he allegedly approached two
officers in a police van he asked them
for directions and then opened fire one
of the officers was struck in the neck
the bullet narrowly missed a vital
artery
that officer was released from the
hospital yesterday it is only by the
grace of God that we are not talking
about police officers murdered the
number of police officers killed in the
line of duty has risen in recent years
according to the FBI 55 officers died as
a result of criminal acts in 2018 that's
a nearly 20 percent increase from the
year before some people blame the
violence on what they see as vicious
anti police rhetoric I don't care what a
politician gets up there and talks about
I want to see what policies that they're
actually passing that are supporting the
police and you're not seeing it
Steve pomper of the National Police
Association says politicians speaking
harshly about police officers has
deepened law enforcement's distrust of
elected officials they didn't want those
people attending their memorials their
funerals if something happened because
they knew that they would just hear
those same hollow words the sergeant's
police union tweeted this at the mayor
yesterday mayor de Blasio the members of
the NYPD are declaring war on you we do
not respect you do not visit us in the
hospital's you've sold the NYPD to the
vile creatures the 1% who hate cops
would vote for you NYPD cops have been
assassinated because of you this is a
game over game on a lot of people were
shocked by that
a lot of people supported it tony has it
this morning that tweet has not been
deleted but an attack there David thank
you very much